all right one other clip i wanted to
play for you today before we move on
this is really funny but also very very
disturbing
rick santorum is a former republican
senator and he often does commentary on
cnn he may even be like sort of on staff
as a
political analyst for cnn at this point
after tuesday night's debate between
donald trump and joe biden
the topic of donald trump not denouncing
white supremacists and armed militias
came up
you remember that this was not a good
moment for donald trump and even fox
news
said trump missed the layup he should
have just denounced them and rick
santorum
it's almost inadvertent rick sam it's
not even clear rick santorum realized it
says well listen it's tough because
trump doesn't want to criticize his
supporters and santorum doesn't even
seem to get that he's conceding
white supremacists are trump supporters
take a look at this video
where he was asking the president do
something that he knows the president
doesn't like to do
which is which is say something bad
about people who support him
right what declining violence well
talking about the white supremacists
yeah the white supremacists number one
and number two
trump doesn't like to say bad things
about his supporters talking about trump
not denouncing white supremacists isn't
that just the best
that's republican commentator rick
santorum although
i'm not sure how pro-trump rick santorum
has has been over the years i just don't
pay attention to rick santorum maybe
he's been
mildly anti-trump i don't know uh but
absolutely fascinating and you can tell
from the look on rick's face
that as he's saying it he realizes what
the logical conclusion of that comment
is when you're saying trump's not going
to now to denounce people that support
him you're saying white supremacists
support trump and of course they do
uh it's one of these there's a phrase
that uh has come up often
uh not all republicans are racist but
the racists overwhelmingly support
republicans and much like that of course
most trump supporters aren't white
supremacists that's a small portion
but white supremacists are
overwhelmingly supporters of donald
trump
a true moment of candor inadvertently
in some sense let me know what you think
i'm on twitter at deepakman
we have a great program for you today
i'm glad you're this is actually a good
one we might save this one as opposed to
deleting it
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent
cash back and lets you create 36 credit
cards a month
and a 25 a month plan tailored more for
small businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman